the wire sets itself apart from other
cop shows in its first season but the
way all five seasons work together to
illustrate a broader message is what
really sets the show apart from other TV
shows altogether this video is sponsored
by Nord bpn I think you need a lot of
context to seriously examine anything
each season of The Wire doesn't just
continue the story but adds a new layer
of context to the show's examination of
Baltimore's institutions and characters
season 1 sets up a problem the
ineffectiveness of the war on drugs and
seasons two through five show why the
problem isn't being solved by economics
politics education and the media and how
each of these things contribute to
keeping the systems in a cycle of
failure the opening scene of each season
serves to illustrate the thesis of that
season the opener to season 1 serves as
a thesis for both season 1 and the
entire show officer McNulty sits with
the witness of a recent murder the
witness who never appears again on the
show laments the unnecessary death of
snotboogie who kills not it's not been
doing the same since all know how long
kill a man over some bullish miss Napoli
always stole the money why'd you let him
play
got this America man America indeed the
game is the game and anyone is free to
play it but that doesn't keep it from
being rigged corrupt or having severe
consequences season one is one of my
favorites it works so well as a
contained a story some by snapping
pictures they got the whole damn thing
someone snapping pictures got the whole
deal nicely done it's circular nature
and the book ending of the beginning and
end of the season was what originally
convinced me of the wires brilliance
lester done but this isn't just clever
story structure it serves to illustrate
how everything in the world of the wire
sits in a kind of stasis how cyclical
and resistant to change
everything is the ending of season 1
provides no significant catharsis
mirroring how the show will end while a
bond is caught stringer bell goes by
without a charge catch you later
kima is shot which prompts an early
shutdown of the case before it can bring
in all its targets those we've been
rooting for all season get punished by
their respective institutions D'Angelo
fails to successfully reform and doesn't
flip and the death of Wallace one of the
most vulnerable and lovable characters
in season 1 sets the tone for the entire
show no character is safe and includes
us into the fact that the wire is going
to go to some dark places in the process
of exploring its themes no meaningful
change occurs within the institutions
only a few individuals change for the
better and some of them change for the
worse the second season of the show is
one of the most controversial the story
makes a hard right turn from the
characters and primary narrative
followed in season 1 and spends a lot of
its time focused on a new set of
dockworkers TV viewers are more used to
this kind of maneuver in a show these
days many of us have watched anthology
shows or shows that evolved extensively
from one season to the next but season
two at the time of the wires release was
startling to audiences it is however a
vital season for two reasons first what
the departure from the primary
narrative signals to the audience about
the show the departure from the main
storyline is uncomfortable audiences
want to spend time with the characters
they already know and love but that
shift signals that the story being told
is about more than just the characters
we met in season one while much of the
show will continue to revolve around
those characters storylines season 2
marks the show's first expansion adding
one of those additional layers of
Baltimore to the scope of the show the
second reason why season two is
important is that it's the first step in
illustrating part of why people move
into the illicit drug trade in the first
place I'm done I'm out I don't need
nothing more to do it you people I don't
need the trouble or the money I got a
union a run it illustrates how the
failing economy incentivizes people to
find alternative sources of income they
used to make steel then Oh
smoke from the stacks
but inside and importantly it shows that
the institutional and systemic failure
isn't just a race issue it's also a
class issue the opening scene again sets
up the thesis how they used to work
there that steel and the shipyards there
yeah and it uncle who was a supervisor
there got laid off in 78 though
73 from my dad the images of the
decaying ports are shown in contrast to
the image of a Baltimore police boat
pulling a boat from Washington named
capital gains you told us somewhere out
of the way
band plays aren't a lot longer
throughout the season we'll see how the
police department is used by people and
power for their own personal gain
while the investigation in season one
was sparked by McNulty's plea to a judge
for change in season two the
investigation is motivated by major
valchek's desire for petty revenge
against Frank Sobotka need a detail CID
people mostly though I could spare some
bodies out of my district to what for I
got some guys in the southeast that are
showing a lot of money
the seasons wiretap investigation will
take a long time to get up and running
the show subverts expectations for the
storyline by actively resisting a the
gangs back together type of moment
carvers in Southeast now he's got second
a tool I mean it'd be great to have
caught we're on this right it's what we
don't even know what the hell was
supposed to be chasing here since the
wire is expecting that you've paid
attention much of the details of running
the wiretap are left out or abbreviated
this season this trend will continue
through the show each seasons wiretaps
storyline becoming more condensed making
room for other subjects another key
element of season two is illustrating
why characters stay in a bad situation
maybe if I had listened your mother
because she's the one always talking
about you should do the community
college like your brother
pop-pop dumped mirroring Wallace's
inability to leave the city for good in
season 1 season 2 shows how the
generational nature of the dockworkers
fuels a desire to continue where they
are even when that situation may not be
the best for them the nature of what
motivates Nick and Ziyi into crime is
important as well as a mere stringer
Bell and Avon Nick and stringers
motivations are more purely economic be
fun as a package a week I seen on the
bank while Avon and Ziggy's have more to
do with feeling empowered this is
reminding me
you a handle that business better to see
we're making money
Avon is obviously more successful and
calculating than Zig ever is but both
their motivations come not from wanting
economic gain itself but from their
desire for respect and to have control
over the production of gain season 3
sees the introduction of politics we've
seen how economic dysfunction creates
and propagates crime institutions in
season 2 now we'll see why these aren't
easily solved political issues and how
the attempts to solve these problems can
often backfire creating new unintended
consequences the opening scene of the
season acts as an image of the
government caught in a cycle of creating
solutions to problems it has helped
create and then tearing down those
solutions as a solution to the
unintended issues created by their
original solution we also see the
citizens cheering for the destruction of
an old solution and everyone being
caught off guard by the side effects of
the new solution season 3 again subverts
expectations for the wiretap storyline
by picking up on the investigation in
full swing but it's struggling three
months and we've yet to hear his voice
the season also contains the wires
closest thing to an explicit political
argument the development of Hamsterdam
major Colvin's attempt to solve the drug
problem through unofficial regulated
legalization might legalize drugs
is the wired argument for legalization
and regulation as a potential solution
they arrested every dude out there for
tipping back a high life there'd be no
other time any other kind of pulleys but
even here I think the wire handles the
issue well the government showed it to
good
come on let me show you Doug showing
with a great degree of nuance the
difficulties involved with this approach
even as it argues for it the dope fiend
come down here cow bellows something an
area so Haslam Chavez in police they
just let him be it's a good thing
understand this story line is where the
season mirrors the irony found in the
opening scene the image of the
government proudly destroying public
housing to solve a crime problem created
in part by corrupt policing is seen in
the destruction of Hamsterdam an
unofficial solution to a problem the
city helped to create season four in my
opinion is one of the most important
seasons of the wire seasons one through
three examined the institution's on and
above the street level that hold crime
in place while season four examines an
institution below the street level so to
speak the season-opener subtly begins to
probe the theme of education Snoop is
educated by the store clerk about the
nail guns you might want to consider the
powder-actuated tool the hill TDX 460 MX
or the Simpson PTP
he's two of my Cadillacs she's motivated
to learn and is a fast learner when the
subject is relevant to her and she
learns by relating that knowledge to
what she knows guns
will see this play out repeatedly
through season 4 with our band of kids
the numbers you can calculate the odds
Michael have four diamonds showily
what about guys I mean those guys have
eyes too because mostly that's what we
play it's not that they're unable or
unwilling to learn in fact they're quite
sharp and adaptive it's that what
they're learning in school has little
relevance to the reality they live on
the streets this theme is supported by
the fact that major Colvin's project to
seize success by meeting those kids
where they are without season four we
never see how the characters shown in
seasons one through three ended up where
they are we might be left to assume that
those characters are in the position
they're in just because of their own
choices or fate season four however
presents a more difficult and complex
answer it's not so simple as a one
individual's choice to enter a life of
crime or become a corrupt police officer
every influence around you acts as a
magnet drawing you towards certain
outcomes but it's also never as simple
as mere fate and those magnetic
influences come from institutions which
are made up of the sum of all the
choices of all the individuals within
that institution the way season 4
relates to the school system and the
police department strengthens the
argument that it's not just the
Baltimore Police Department or mayor's
office that has a problem it's the way
institutions themselves are run and
structured that can create negative
incentives and again Colvin's project
like Hamsterdam while it sees success is
dismantled by an institution that's
afraid of appearances but you wouldn't
be teaching test curriculum here do
these would be that children left behind
so to speak
but as it is I mean where we leave them
all behind anyway we should someone did
bid it season five gets a bad rap and I
won't argue that it's the lowest quality
season of The Wire the departure of Ed
Burns from the writing staff weakened
the writing team and it shows in an
attention to detail and realism and
storytelling that doesn't quite live up
to the standard of past seasons that
said season five is still a critical
part of the narrative that the wire is
constructing it shows why media when it
looks at everything that the previous
seasons examined also fails to create
meaningful change in many ways I think
the narrative of the newspaper in season
five is a reflection of many of the
struggles the wire itself faced here you
have a TV show that is attempting to
seriously examine real difficult themes
and it's completely overlooked by the
industry Awards in favor of more
sensational content just like the
stories that are being considered for
awards in season five are the more
sensational stories instead of the more
important ones but it isn't just Awards
before it became somewhat of a cult hit
when the DVDs came out the wire
struggled to keep viewership and
repeatedly had to fight to get renewed
McNulty's crazy scheme to invent a
serial killer to get the attention of
the press and by proxy readers in a way
mirrors David Simon's frustration that
more sensational shows got higher
viewership while the wire went largely
unnoticed as a serial killer but he only
became an officer again the opening
scene tips us off to the broader theme
of the season deception and how it's
used within institutions and by
individuals to game those institutions
being Adlai
the story of each character and the
stories within each season of the lier
are important and significant but I
think the most impressive aspect of the
show is the way it all works together in
concert to illustrate the city of
Baltimore and its different institutions
the show illustrates how incredibly
complex the problems it talks about are
and how difficult finding a solution for
those problems is every season of The
Wire helps strengthen its argument and
adds details and context to that
argument
the seasons aren't just arbitrary chunks
of the story to divide production time
and distribution their parts in the book
working together to do something no TV
show had done before thank you so much
to Nord VPN for sponsoring this video a
VPN is a critical part of protecting
your privacy on the Internet Nord VPN is
a VPN that I've been using for years
they have thousands of servers that are
very fast I've never had speed issues
and you can have up to six simultaneous
connections they have military-grade
encryption and a risk free 30-day
money-back guarantee as issues like
article 13 come to the forefront having
a VPN is only going to become more and
more important I recommend you have a
VPN and I recommend you use north VPN
you can go to Nord VPN comm slash Thomas
plate to get 75% off a three-year plan
and you can use code Thomas flight to
get an extra month for free that's Nord
VPN comm slash thomas flight to get 75%
off that three year plan and use code
thomas flight for an extra month free
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this video thank you so much
to my patreon supporters if you want to
learn more about how you can get access
to the bonus videos I create you can go
to patreon.com/scishow